so for example we know at the
energetic component I'm going to spiral
rotate the lower
tonden that means I got
to spin it down spin it right spin it
left spin it up okay and the symbol for
that is
this at the physical Marshall level
this is also the symbol for a constant
90 90° fluctuation to the angle of
resistance so my patterns have to end
up or they will end up for both Marshal
and energetic
reasons tracing this figure eight and so
when we do the second part of EO you're
going to see how we did that so in this
version
if uh for myi if UK is coming in this
way and let's say my left hand is
forward and I'm going to start with this
kind of
shape but very quickly this part comes
around and I start making this figure
eight okay so here it is where I enter
and then they're going to come around me
again okay
and then because you have to keep that
shape you're going to do it again over
here okay you do it again over here so
you kind of have in this variation two
fig two figure eights going and this
this is where the technique will
end again from my me home and I goess
and now I have to go this way and I've
went this way I'm not going to pull him
over and I am not going to some people
think they're going around and not
pulling him but they're
not so when I step over here like
this I'm pulling
him I have to half moon
always so my foot will come by the other
foot and now I do another Ed me over
here on that same
turn so over here I come by I have
another
entry then the technique ends you bring
your foot
over and you do Co Yoku
two
three different
[Music]
try Okay so let's let's look at how I'm
moving so so this knee has to go to the
Yong which means my knee goes over my
toes and now I have a angle in my lower
leg that I can drive my hips
into so the same thing here knee to toes
then I can drive
in
out knee to
toes then I come in
here not here
so uh when I try to step I want you to
push push me over so here I
am kind I you have to go here then I can
do
it same thing here he he pushes on me I
can't get over there can't get that foot
off so I have to go here first one here
and then around easy here here
down okay so bring that knee into y so
that you could
aumi okay now we'll look at the rate so
the rate is
constant whether it's slow or fast I'm
not going to go
here
stop then go you're having to stop
because you can't
ground the rate is constant I move at a
constant rate
either it's slow or
quick constant R okay the Keon they're
like I said they have like a mythical
framework a mythical narrative framework
so they don't they're not literal they
tell you a bunch of things all at once
hidden okay so for as I'm doing this
pattern that I have just the foot
pattern that's all I want to look at we
know I could snap the arm here
okay and uh as I come
around stay there just tap when you
don't like it okay so as I come around
I'm going to rip this shoulder off so on
this foot maneuver here
that one I have this chicken wing I just
pull the whole shoulder off
okay that's what you have here we let it
out in the keyone but it's there this
pressure here as I'm moving with my body
makes that
happen now you have another mythical
element I can break the arm at the other
angle so as I come this way you'll tap
when he doesn't like it
this one's going forward this one was
going back this way now this one's going
forward this way I can rip the shoulder
off at that angle too okay I'm going to
let him turn out a little turn with me
which I often let UK do that so I don't
rip the shoulder but here's that step
out and here's the break another break
this time go back
not from the top
down go back but this one's from the
inside this way right learn that too
okay then the c ends in
coku
additionally when I have Arm
Control on
somebody that meaning I'm controlling
the center from from the arm he can
either stop me from coming in you see
and so here's that
line I can't get there so when I move
over here it's not there anymore I I
went around the
resistance and let's say you're still
pushing that way then this is
easy I go around the resistance and this
allows the shoulder to go back down
the other thing he can
do is he going to pull
in you see well this is why those braks
are so important okay so he goes to pull
in you're going with
it and this opens the door for a temi
because he has a Yin yield you see so I
don't want to be pulled by it I go with
it boom and I kick him right in the
face now I attack the center line
directly and now I can go back to the
arm so all that is in there okay so
let's look for those
markers can you rip the shoulder out at
those two different angles can you break
the arm on the first one from the top on
the second one from the inside and then
can you kick that face then then the
last thing is just a tail end hey let's
do some cou hole all let's try so I'm
not showing the handw workk like I want
you to focus on the pattern and the
mechanics of the pattern okay the
handwork is very
particular so I got
probably 80 90% of the dishy here today
are not doing the hand workk okay it's
very particular I will say this because
it's such a common tendency and there's
no way you can get my hand workk until
you let go of this
I do
not uh have to shove anything
down so as he's
pushing I'm going to
yield so I don't need any muscle to keep
this in
place I yield and I bring his elbow
up now this hand generates this much
tilt by bringing his elbow to the other
side of my
head not by pushing him
away but by taking his elbow to the
other side of my head and now I just
lengthen the hand as I step
in and it takes no muscle to do any of
that you don't even need the
elbow and so when I come around this
thing I don't have to shove it down
here I don't have to shove it around
either I'm at the distal end of the
lever and I'm not pushing it down I'm
just not letting it come up so he tries
to come up you'll feel my sunk chees
and now I just work the distal end of
the lever
boom and I'm going around like this then
the same thing I don't want to drop it
where his strength is it keeps going
around on the
circle and it
drops so there's none of this
I had your back
Sensei there's none of
this I don't have to do that I just keep
the
pow goes around me and I go around
this around me and I go around this
because what I'm really moving is his
body I'm moving the body
I move the
body move the body